[Music]
kastlevania has just wrapped up its
second season and with double the amount
of episodes that its predecessor had
there's a lot to unpack throughout this
video I'll be discussing the ending of
Castlevania season 2 and where it leaves
the characters there will be heavy
spoilers and it's definitely worth
skipping this video for now if you're
yet to see it with that out the way I'm
definition and I ruin the show so you
don't have to with Dracula now dead alia
card decides to stay with the castle
claiming it as his legacy normally this
would be quite a triumphant moment for
the character but in the final scene of
the show where we see him crying heavily
this is because he is finally able to
feel the crushing loneliness that his
father did before he met his mother
it's a sorrowful ending that really
pinpoint why Dracula acted the way that
he did throughout the show Dracula was
on a suicide mission after the death of
his wife and his hate for Humanity was
the reasoning behind why he wanted to
wipe out the species they even got to
the point that other vampires disagreed
with his motives due to their sauce food
being non-existent should he succeeds
this still didn't bother Dracula though
as without his love he was unable to
feel anything it's this crushing
depression that led to the character's
demise on the whole his peers ended up
betraying him with only his most trusted
servant remaining loyal in the final
battle the series antagonists even
forfeited the fight due to being racked
with guilt over the fact that he was
attempting to murder his own son this
allowed Ally Cod to finally finish him
off and take his place
this doesn't make it any easier for Ally
card though and with the series
branching off into so many different
directions I wonder if the new ruler of
the castle will succumb to the same
madness that motivated his father season
2 saw the arrival of Camilla a
Castlevania fan favorite Camilla seemed
to be the only character who was willing
to shake up the foundations of the
supernatural society and with Dracula
now dead she has an opportunity to take
his place
heavily foreshadow throughout season two
I can definitely see this being the
route that season three takes and it
makes sense with her being such a strong
story element in the games her plans to
usurp Dracula throughout season to
showcase that she has the drive to rule
and this makes the most sense going
forward actor and Isaac to have the
potential to play big parts and their
rivalry will likely come to a head on
the third season of the show season two
introduce these two twisted human
characters as defectors that were
willing to do Dracula's bidding in the
end
Isaac remained loyal to his master
whereas Hector ended up enslaved by
Camilla by the show's close Isaac has
begun an uprising with the undead and is
headed back towards Dracula's location
which is where he will likely discover
the events that have transpired this
could prove to be chaotic for Camilla as
the character will now possess a lot of
hate towards her in the games Isaac and
Hector ended up facing off against one
another and their dislike for each other
is definitely hinted at throughout the
second season this would be the perfect
subplot for the third outing of the show
and I definitely think you will see the
two Bay's off against one another down
the line juxtaposing the dour endings
that the rest of the characters face are
Trevor and cipher infinitely more
optimistic than Alucard the two former
friendship that sees them joining forces
to face whatever lies ahead in the game
series that yuo end up married to one
another and even end up having a son
named Simon fans of the franchise will
recognize him as the titular character
in Castlevania to Simon's quest and this
heir to the Belmont clan becomes a
mainstay in the series that I can
definitely see the creator's deciding to
follow and future incarnations of the
show as of yet Netflix have made no
official announcement regarding season 3
but richard armitage who voices Trevor
bellman told Digital Spy in tune that
they were in the process of recording a
third season for the show obviously
there is a lot of potentially different
things that could happen in season 3 so
if you have any theories going forward
please comment below and let me know if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my ending
explain breakdown of the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina which will be
linked at the end of this video this is
the channel for people who are heavy
into horror so up that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]